hi I'm Keith daniken welcome to cloud
on-air live webinars from Google cloud
we're hosting webinars every Tuesday
today I'm going to talk about how to
connect api's with existing identity
management systems you can ask questions
any time on the platform and we'll have
Googlers standing by to answer them so
let's get started so here's our agenda
for today I'm gonna do a brief overview
of appaji edge so you can see what that
looks like I'm going to talk about
Identity Management and how you can
integrate that with your existing api's
so how would you take your existing
api's and add them so that they can
authenticate against your identity
management system both on the front and
on the back after that we'll do
questions and answers so let's get
started with a overview of appaji edge
and what that is at a very high level so
this describes the philosophy for Apogee
edge Apogee seen a repeated pattern of
success with its customers and it's
driven by how they think about their API
program and it requires a shift in how
you think about this so traditionally we
think about this from an exposure point
of view you could just expose a service
and be finished but thinking about it
from the end users point of view leads
to much better results our successful
customers start from the user thinking
about what that users experience will be
like and then working backwards from
there providing the application
developer with great api's will reduce
the complexity of creating new
applications the developer is free to
focus on user experience and iterate on
a few different designs the API team
makes this possible by providing easy to
use API is with consistent interfaces
and security the API team builds the an
API facade on existing services
abstracting away the complexities hide
away all that Enterprise stuff
Appaji edge makes it easy for your API
team to build great api's and Apogee
edge also makes it easy for developers
to consume those api's it also lets you
measure every aspect of your API program
so here's a pudgy edge let's talk about
what's inside Appaji edge is a single
platform with three conceptual parts API
services allows you to expose and manage
services to an API developer services
provides a portal where application
developers or API can see
can learn about your API s and request
access to them and analytic services
lets you measure every aspect of your
API program so let's look at these three
parts in a little bit more detail so for
API services this is where we build API
so this is the bulk of what we're going
to be doing when we think about
integrating with things on the Left
we're gonna have applications maybe a
mobile application a web application or
some sort of partner system these
applications make API calls they're
gonna send HTTP requests in Appaji edge
lets you pass that request
straight through the back-end system
where you can change anything about it
in the header is the URI or the body you
can even do intelligent routing based on
the caller
maybe there's different back-end systems
you want to send them to you can also
manage the flow of traffic by improves
imposing rate limits or quotas and you
can apply caching so you have complete
control over the request and the reply
in there when the backend system returns
a response you can send that response
straight to the application or change it
around as needed for example you might
want to reduce the payload to a mobile
client or transform XML into JSON so
after you build some great api's you
want to make it easy for your developers
to discover them and start using them
the developer portal gives you a place
to put your documentation and tools to
let your developers register for access
developers can try out your API is from
documentation they can fill in data
fields see what the requests in response
looks like and the developer portal is
going to greatly reduce the friction
when getting started with api's so this
is your one-stop shop for all your
developers rather than having meetings
with them or sharing PDF documents or
anything like that you've got a nice
website where they can go and they can
get registered and NC Doc's so after you
built a few api's in your application
developers have discovered them and
started to send you traffic it'd be
great if you could measure your API
program the analytic system and Appaji
edge allows you to measure every aspect
of your API traffic you can measure
operational details like response time
and frequency of different types of
errors you can find things that are
interesting to your business like where
people located when they call your API
is or which applications are sending the
most traffic maybe it's interesting to
see what type of client they're using
are they on chrome are they on Firefox
are they on iOS or Android you can get
details like that in analytic services
and you can add your own custom metrics
in here so if you want to measure
something that's specific to your
program
grab that other request of the response
and connect that with some of the
existing out-of-the-box analytics and
get full detailed reports on that so
let's talk about our demo today we're
going to talk about how to integrate
with an eidm system or identity
management system there's a few types of
authentication we might need to consider
when we're building api's we may just
need to identify which applications call
in our API is it a website application
is it an iOS app is it an Android app
but in addition to knowing which
applications calling our API we might
need to authenticate the end-user who's
actually using the application maybe
we've got something in there this a
little more sensitive maybe it's a
banking application or something like
that
also our back-end services might require
some authentication and that might be
different from what we're doing with the
users so in a lot of cases we'll want to
separate front-end authentication from
back-end authentication we might have a
variety of different authentication
mechanisms on the back side but we want
to provide a single consistent way of
authenticating when you call an API when
I hide away the gory details to the
backend authentication from our API
consumers and you might have multiple
ways of authenticating calls to that
back-end system depending on which
back-end system you're calling and when
it was built so we want to provide a
facade on the front that gives
consistency to all of the api's so let's
consider an example where you need to
authenticate end-users using it an
external identity management system and
call a back-end service that uses a
service account that requires the
username and password in the form of
basic authentication well prompt the
user for their username and password and
we'll store the username and password in
the back end in Appaji ski value map so
in this case what we're doing is on that
left hand side there we're gonna ask
them for user name and password and on
the right hand side it's a completely
different username and password to get
into that system the identity management
system could be anything it might be an
off-the-shelf thing that you've already
got in place might be a cloud-based
identity management system might be your
corporate LDAP in this case I'm making a
generic so we can look at examples of
how this could work so here's what our
authentication flow might look like
let's consider a request
let's consider a request from the users
in there now look at the application on
the left hand side there let's look at
the business flow first when the user
comes in they're not going to have an
authentication token so they would go
down to that authentication flow and get
a token the authentication flow would
talk to an identity management system
and then at the end of that it's going
to generate a token so if you've got
that token you flow through that top
path easily so that token is sent as a
request header we're gonna check that
token we're going to apply a little bit
of traffic control in the form of that
spiked arrest that will keep us from
calling too quickly keep the backend
from getting overwhelmed I'm gonna
remove the header and that's going to
remove that security header because it's
not required for the backend well grab
the credentials for the backend using
the key value map and then we'll set a
new basic off header in there before it
goes to the backend using that identity
so one identity on the left hand side in
the form of that Bo auth token and one
identity on the right hand side in the
form of a user basic header so where do
you get that token that's where the
authentication flow on the bottom comes
in so let's assume the application
connects it doesn't have a token it's
going to get back in HTTP 401 and that
means they're not authorized
so that application will know to call
out to a token flow where he can get an
access token so we pass in a username
and password to the authentication flow
that is going to call out to an identity
management system so that first blue
arrow there is a call out to identity
management system and we're going to
assume it has an HTTP endpoint on it so
we call out to that if the username and
password is good it'll return at 200 to
us and if that works
we'll continue if not that second thing
in there bad off will fire and that will
return an error letting the application
know that the username and password
wasn't good so if that does work we're
gonna collect some things from the
identity management system there might
be some things in there about what their
role is and we could use that later on
for authorization figuring out what
they're allowed to do and what they're
not allowed to do from there we'll look
up the keys that are specific to this
API that the user is requesting a token
for and then we'll generate the token
and that's an OAuth token that will be
returned to the user so then that's
returned up to the application and the
application then has the token so if you
an analogy for this think about when you
go to a festival or something like that
and you're given a wristband and that
wristband might be a different color
depending on what day it is or what
you're allowed to do maybe folks over 21
or given one one color because they're
allowed to go and drink and other folks
are given a different color because
they're not so there's a credential
that's presented in the form of a
driver's license or something like that
and then that is exchanged for a token
which would be the wristband and the
wristband gives you different
entitlements based on what it looks like
we can use that analogy to describe what
this flow would look like so let's dig
into the API proxy and see what that
looks like inside of appaji edge so
here's a pudgy edge if you haven't seen
this before let me jump out and give a
little bit of a tour so when we first
come into here we're greeted with this
screen this is where we're going to
build API proxies so in this case we're
playing the role of the API developer we
also have application developers that
will consume our API s that's a group
different group of developers so let's
focus on API development what I would do
when I come in here I'm gonna click on
API proxies I've got a list in here of
API proxies I want to build a new one I
can come up to this button and hit plus
API proxy few different options in there
most commonly I'm gonna build a reverse
proxy I might have a spec for it if I
have an open API here swagger spec for
that I could build my API proxy using
that maybe I got a soap service I could
come down and use that there's a wizard
in there to convert soap to rest rest to
so I can digest a Wizzle and it'll make
a conversion thing in there no target
allows us to create a stubbed out
interface so we're gonna come up with
the response right there in the proxy
we've got hosted functions and no js'
they're both going to allow us to host
something in nodejs inside of appaji
edge and then proxy bundle would let us
import an existing zip file so in most
cases I'm going to do reverse proxy and
we come in here proxy name base path and
then an existing URL so I would walk
through this wizard and then the end of
it I end up on a development screen I'm
going to show you guys a pre-built one
so let's go back and look at our
Identity Management example so in this
case I'm calling a back-end system
that's an employee directory and it
requires a username and password and
it's a system username and password it's
just basically a service account but on
the other side I want to authenticate my
users against our identity management
system so I would end up on a summary
screen like this this is the URL that
I'll call and then this is the backend
system that it's going to call by proxy
click over on the develop tab here and
we'll see what's going on in there so
here's the flow I was talking about
before what we're gonna see in here is
there's a number of policies up here and
then we've got some code down here on
the bottom that configures what those
policies do so policies that are
available this is the request flow and
the response flow we can put whatever we
like in here if I click up here we'll
see that there's a number of policies
for traffic management for response
caching working with caches populating
them invalidating them
warming them up that sort of thing all
kinds of things with cache either
through a policy or programmatically
through an API call lots of policies
around security we're gonna use the
OAuth policy in here a lot of things
around mediation so converting between
formats returning custom error messages
things like that and then custom
extensions so if we want to do things
with Java or Python or JavaScript we can
do that and I'm gonna make use of the
service call out in here to call out to
identity management system so let's go
through here and see what's in here
so first thing I've got in here is I'm
going to check and make sure that they
have an access token so I want to verify
their access token and make sure it's
valid so if it's not valid we're going
to send back an unauthorized err and if
it is valid flow will continue over to
the right here so first thing to do is
we've got a lots 2.0 policy in there and
then this configures it I've got it in
verify access token mode there's a bunch
of different operations that can do and
I've chosen to have it on verify access
mode spike arrest is next so spike
arrest will reduce our it'll limit the
frequency at which somebody can call so
I've limited the
- ten calls per minute if they call
faster than that I'm going to return an
error message you might also use a quota
policy in here that's a fixed number of
calls so one would control the rate at
which you can call the other will be a
fixed quota of number of calls per day
per hour per minute the quota tends to
be more business-related what you've
agreed with the customer and then the
spike rest is there really just to
protect your systems and keep somebody
from just hammering the system next
thing I'm gonna do in here is remove the
header so we've sent in an authorization
header with that token but we don't want
to send that to the backend system
because it doesn't understand it it
doesn't need it anything like that so
what this is going to do is actually
remove the header from the request
before it sends that request on to the
back-end system so remove the
authorization header and the next one is
we're gonna do get credentials so get
credentials in here what that's gonna do
is it's a key value map operation and
we're going to look up the username and
the password for the backend system so
we'll have those as variables in the
system and then we can use them in the
next step these are stored in a key
value map so there's an encrypted key
value map in here and that's under the
environment tab we'll find that over on
this side and I'll take a look at that
later this will set a basic
authentication header so we're going to
take that username and password that we
got in the previous step and we're going
to create a basic auth header so that's
a base64 encoded string of the username
and password and that's what our
back-end system understands and then
that goes to the back-end system and we
should be logged in and we should get
data back I'm not doing any processing
on the return but I could reformat the
response or anything like that if I want
so let's take a look at at this step
here where did we get these credentials
from so let's go over here and take a
look I'm gonna click on environment over
here and what we'll see in here is that
we've got a few different settings so
we've got different caches we can have
they can be associated with different
environments we can have flow hooks
references target servers I'm gonna look
at key value maps that's what's
interesting to me so I have lots of
passwords for back-end systems in here
and I keep them stored in here so this
is this is where they all are you can
look them up by value so look up the key
and then you get back the
value and that's where my employee
directory user name and password they're
gonna be stored in here and that's where
I get them I could have different
credentials for my different
environments my production environment
my test environment QA staging whatever
my environment happens to be I can have
a map for each of those so if you have
different credentials for those
different environments
we'd automatically be able to get the
right one depending on where this
thing's deployed so that's where that
came from
so that's an example of how we might
build a simple API proxy that would
integrate with our existing identity
management system so that was the
business flow and that's what checks the
token but where we get that token where
did that come from so let's take a look
at the token flow and see where the
token actually came from so I have
another flow in here that is going to
return tokens for me and in this case
we're gonna do some checking of that
actual username and password before we
return a token to somebody so here's the
flow for that I've got a spike arrest in
here and that's going to prevent
somebody from calling this too quickly
but if we notice down here under proxy
endpoints we've got a few different
flows down here so this pre flow is
called all the time no matter how I call
this proxy and then there's conditional
things in between there and then there's
a post flow that is called
unconditionally after that in this case
if I call this with an HTTP POST
and I'm calling slash token this logic
gets executed so this is the actual flow
we're going to get the token so the
first thing here is we're gonna
authorize the user so in this case what
we're doing is we're going to send in
the username and password that was sent
to us we're gonna send that over to the
authorization system and have it check
this for us so the URL for the system is
down here and then here is the actual
body of the payload that I'm going to
send in so I'm gonna do an HTTP POST I'm
gonna send in the username and the
password and then I'm going to get back
a response and I'm gonna store that in
IDM response I'm well I will allow 15
seconds for that to happen if that
doesn't happen we're gonna get a timeout
care so that's the actual call to the
system if it fails if it returns
something that's not a 200 we're gonna
have this
fire and it's gonna say invalid username
and password you can put whatever you
like in there whatever makes sense maybe
some guidance on how to deal with that
or hints on how that might work so as
long as it returns okay that'll be
skipped and we'll go onto here there's a
session token that's returned and I want
to grab that out of there so that will
give me some information from the
identity management system it's going to
return a session token and a few other
things but basically what I'm counting
on here is that I got back at 200 from
the identity management system and then
if there's any other metadata in there
I'll grab that out in this case it's a
session token and we'll take that in
this next step here we're going to set
some keys for our API so that's where
we're going to set our API keys for the
token we're gonna generate and then
finally this generates the token so
we're doing a password grant type and
we're going to build a token and we're
going to return that to the user and
we'll take a look at that in a second so
we can see what that float looks like so
the user name and password are I'm sorry
the user name and the session token are
the two attributes we're gonna stick on
there when we generate a token with a
pudgy edge you can stick any kind of
metadata you want in there so this might
be identity information that you grabbed
from your identity management system
what Department they work in a billing
code a partner ID anything like that
these get populated as variables
whenever that token flows through the
system and we can use that for dynamic
routing we could use it for dynamic
rate-limiting we can control what
they're doing and how they are routed
through the system and things like that
that generates our token so that's our
two flows one of them is the business
flow that's going to connect to the
back-end system and it requires a token
and then this flow is the token flow and
it'll generate tokens for us so that we
can send them to the application and it
can be used to call things so let's look
at what those look like from the command
line so to speak so in this case here's
my identity management system what I've
got here is a tool that lets me just
call rest based endpoints so I'm gonna
call up the identity management system
the tokens and then the the actual
business app so the identity management
system what I like to do when I'm when
I'm building this is I'll pull up a tool
like this and I'll prototype my API
so what does it take to call that
back-end system what can I send in there
and what will I get back and how is that
going to work so if I send in my
username and password to this this is
what I get back I've gotten back a 200
ok and that means that I'm ok if I come
in here and I change my username in
there and I send that in we're gonna go
back a 401 unauthorized so those are the
two responses I can get from the system
and the password here it's using a
variable so that we can't see the
password so that's the identity
management system directly that's what
we're doing that call out to the token
flow where we're calling Apogee we're
going to send in the username and
password it'll send it out to the
identity management system if it gets
back that 200 then it continues and it
returns us a Apogee Roth token and that
will look like this
so here's our token that comes back
we've got a few extra things in there
we've got the user ID in there we put
that on there and then we've got a
session tour a let's see where is it in
here it's a session token so there's a
session token that comes back from the
identity management system we might use
that for logging what's important to me
though is this access token right here
and I'm gonna grab that and copy it and
then here's our business flow so this is
a simple application that lets us look
up employees and we need to have a basic
auth header in here and if we don't have
one it'll say that we're not authorized
so we can come in here and put a value
in there and then we'll paste our token
value in there and when we have a token
will see employees come back so what
this does is we could look up an
employee by name I'm looking for anybody
named Smith here and that's what I'm
seeing come back so the flow is complete
there we pass in a username and password
in an exchange for that we're given a
token and then we use that token in the
business flow and we passed that as a
header on here and that's what gets us
into the system so simple example of how
we might do security mediation so we're
going to use one set of credentials on
the application side we use different
set of credentials on the back-end or
system side nice pattern for putting a
facade on an existing system a lot of
times dealing with security is a big
burden for developers
and being able to have consistent
security for all of these things gonna
make it a lot easier to do okay so let's
look at another example
okay so nice example username and
password for the backend but what if
you're using Google Cloud what if you
need to have a surface account for all
of your different things that you can do
in Google Cloud and you need to get
credentials for that so a somewhat more
complicated use case but once we've
mastered this it's easy to do for any
service in Google cloud so when you want
to access a system in GCP you need to
have a an OAuth token for that in order
to get better off token you've got to
send in a JWT request and it has to be
signed in a particular way and once that
sent in we'll get back that Roth token
it's got a timeout on it and we can
continue to send that as a header so
same pattern here as we saw in the last
one but in this case we're going to do
an Apogee OAuth token over here on the
left hand side and then we're going to
do a GCP token over on the right hand
side so what we're doing in this case is
the authentication flow would be exactly
the same we're going to authenticate the
end user and we're gonna talk to the
identity management system and that is
going to generate a token as that very
last step and then return to the client
and then we've got to verify key on
there as the first step in the business
flow we're doing some rate limiting to
make sure they don't call too quickly
and we're gonna check a quota make sure
that they didn't exceed that quota and
we've got some response caching and
there to speed things up what's new in
here is we are the things that says GCP
authorization and that's a shared flow
so what you can do inside of a PG edge
is you can have a series of flows and
you can have some that you'd like to
share between different API proxies I
build a lot of things that talk to
Google cloud platform so being able to
reuse my authentication is really nice
so I'll put that into a shared flow and
I can include that in multiple API
proxies without having to build it every
time so what we're seeing in here is
there's a shared flow and there's quite
a few steps in there the last step in
here is the one that's important just
like we saw in the last example we need
to have a header in there we need to
have a bearer token an authorization
header and that's the value that we got
back from the Google cloud identity
management system so it sends us that
token and we're going to insert a bearer
token in there as a header and that's
the last step in here the other steps
are what lead to that so I'm gonna call
out to this and the first step in here
is a cache
if I already have that value in cash
maybe I got it a few minutes ago it
lasts 30 minutes I put it in an
in-memory cache I'm just gonna pull it
from that cache if I don't have it in
cash the next steps are to go get it so
in most cases what's gonna happen in
here is we're gonna pull that out of
cache all these steps will be skipped
and then the last step will execute
we'll stick that header in there if we
don't already have that value then all
these things in the middle do execute so
we're gonna look up some keys and
secrets that allow us to talk to the
identity management system we've got a
Java call out in there to build that JWT
and encrypt it the right way we're gonna
make a call out to the identity
management system we're going to extract
some things from the response that comes
back well just a timeout make a little
bit shorter and we're gonna have the
cache have a time to live that's a
little bit shorter than the length of
the token finally in there if it's not
in the right format or we get an error
we're gonna return an error code there
we'll put it in the cache so that next
time we can find it and then we'll set a
variable so that has a well known value
so that's what that flow looks like
little bit more complicated I'll go into
detail in a minute on how this works so
and result to that is we've got a header
and then we can call whatever we're
entitled to with that service account
inside of GCP so let's look at the API
proxy and let's see how I built that so
let's take a look at the shared flow for
that GCP spec so in this case I've got
shared flows in here I'm gonna come in
and look at that so here's GCP auth so
when we're doing a shared flow in Apogee
this screens a little bit simpler and
these aren't intended to be used
standalone they're always included in
something else they become part of
another proxy so we flip over to the
develop tab and we'll take a look at
what's in here so bunch of steps in here
so first one is the cache do we have it
cached if it's already cached just pull
it outta memory and return it skip the
rest of it so that's what's in there
we're gonna look for a value called GCP
token that's a key for it we don't have
that we need to get a few things we need
to get some credentials in there so
we've got the JWT issuer
we've got the private keep em and then
this is our Java call-out so this is
calling a jar file that's stored over
here and we're gonna pass in some values
we want to do RS 256 for the encryption
algorithm we're gonna pass in some
values about who the audience is what
the expiration time is and then what the
claim scope is so this will allow us to
call bigquery and we're gonna get a
token back that's very specific to this
and gives us entitlements to certain
things inside of GCP so here's the
actual call out that will call the URL
so Google API is off to before token so
that's the way of programmatically
getting a token if it's not an
interactive flow if this was an end user
they'd be greeted by the Google login
screen and they'd go through their
credentials and things like that this is
the programmatic way of doing that
before services so we will call out to
that we're going to send it as form
encoded we're gonna send in just the
right perform parameters in there that
JWT that we created and then we're gonna
store the response in token response and
we're gonna consider success either at
200 or 300 code we'll get what we need
out of there which is the access token
and the expiration time so that's the
response that comes back and what we're
doing is we're actually pulling things
out of the response in there we'll
adjust down the expiration time and
shrink it down so it's a little bit less
than the expiration of the token there's
some air handling and then here we're
gonna put it into a cache so we're gonna
go cache that token so that we don't
have to do this every single time
finally we'll set it as a variable and
then this is the thing that gets called
every single time this is where we
actually insert that header in there and
that's what's going to make it so that
we can call the backend system so that's
a typical flow of what we might do in
here and that's how we would go in and
generate a GCP token so let's take a
step back for a minute and and talk
about why are we doing all this so why
not just call the authentication system
every time so in particular this flow
why use an Apogee token in here why
bother with this when you could just
call the authentication system with
every single call and you know it would
give you a credential there so
the idea here is when we want to speed
it up so we want to make it so that it's
faster to call this system so in each
case if we have an Apogee token it's
about a millisecond to check that thing
so pretty fast a call to the
authentication system might take a
little bit longer but more importantly
this Apogee token that we're generating
down here has a lot of metadata
associated with it it's gonna tell us
which API product they're using it's
gonna tell us who the developer is it'll
have any of those attributes that we've
attached to it and with those we can do
dynamic routing we can send people to
different locations we can rate limit
them based on their relationship with us
so we get a lot of additional features
with that that are much better than if
we were just simply checking a username
and password so that's why we're gonna
do that and that's why we're gonna cash
it and do it that way so that's our two
flows let's look at an example of an
application or two applications that use
these and see what those look like so
the first one I showed was the employee
directory and remember in this case
we've got a username and password for
the front-end that's checked against the
identity management system and then a
service account for the back-end so if I
want to come in and check my employee
directory it's gonna require me to
authenticate so let's say I'm searching
for somebody named Smith it's gonna say
I need a username and password so I need
to enter that in there and what it's
going to do is go out and get that token
and then my application will have a
token and when I search I get back
results so if I want to search for
somebody else I can do that I continue
to search until that token is no longer
valid so that's our basic idea behind
that so what does this look like behind
the scenes what's the flow for that this
is a simple single page web application
it's written in JavaScript and what I've
got in here the interesting parts of it
are down here where I'm going to go and
actually call and get a token and where
I'm gonna do the business search so
here's the basic search we're gonna do
our URL in there for the API it's gonna
get back some data and then draw that on
the screen down here is update token so
that's the process for going
a token we're not storing any
credentials in here so this is a
JavaScript application it's in a webpage
somebody can easily hit view source on
this so we don't want the credentials
stored in here we want to be able to go
get it a short-lived access token that
access token is only good for 30 minutes
or whatever we've set that session
timeout to so that's the application for
the password on the front and the
service account on the back this
application is going to call big grain
so what I've got in here is an
application where I can check historical
weather there's a few sample data sets
for bigquery
one of them is historical weather for
North America so I can look at weather
for any city and I can check what the
weather has been for the last 100 years
or so what I did in this case was I
looked up at San Francisco and I wanted
to see what the weather was like in 2015
so two things are happening in here when
I call this it's going to do some
geocoding and look up the location that
I put in here
and then it's going to return a list of
weather stations that are in that area I
can supply it with a year and then it's
going to go and retrieve weather for
that data so they're showing me high
temperature data from January all the
way through December so what's
interesting in here is I'm sending in an
API key on this and then it's doing that
flow in there where it's going to go get
a token it's going to have a service
call out and it's going to get a token
that's appropriate for calling bigquery
with read-only access so that's what's
happening behind the scenes in here I've
applied some rate limiting to this so if
I call it too quickly it's going to shut
me down and things like that but I get
everything I need in the application
it's a nice mix of things I could I
could authenticate people who are going
to call this however I like so there's
my rate limiting kicking in to prevent
somebody from calling that too quickly
but that's the general idea behind this
so that's our applications and that's
what they look like and that's how you
could build something like this so if
you want to learn more about this if
this was interesting to you a few
different resources you can look at you
can go to Apogee comm and sign up for a
free trial when you get to the page
there there's a nice big red button up
in the top that says like try it for
free and that can generate a Google
cloud or a I'm sorry an Apogee account
for you and you can try out these API
proxies build your own things and see
how it works we have some hands-on
enablement if you want to try out a
virtual API Jam or an on-site API Jam
it's a great way to learn an API Jam is
a hands-on workshop either half-day or
full-day and what we do is we go through
this with your team and you guys can go
through some exercises and teach you how
to build basic things in Apogee and
learn how to use the product there's a
number of product demo webinars similar
to this one so take a look at those and
find topics for those I've got all the
URLs posted on this screen if you want
just general information take a look at
Apogee comm and see what you can do with
the product here's some stories about
what other customers have done and how
you can use Apogee to build a fantastic
API program all right at this point
we're gonna take some questions we'll be
back in just a second for questions
you
ok looks like we've got a few questions
here let me read a few of these and
we'll talk about what's in here so first
question I've got is can you integrate
with Active Directory so I hear that a
lot a lot of people are standardized on
Active Directory so if you can reach
your Active Directory we can work with
it so as long as you can reach it
through HTTP or a Java call-out or
JavaScript or Python you can absolutely
integrate with Active Directory so next
question I guess somewhat related
what if our identity management system
doesn't have an HTTP interface will this
still work so what do we do in the case
of that a lot of things I'm thinking
like Oracle access manager Tivoli some
of those they don't necessarily have an
HTTP interface if they have a Java
library you can use that call an API as
long as you can get back some sort of
signal from that back-end thing that
says this user is ok so if there's
really any way to call it we can use
this same pattern to integrate with that
identity management system what about
two-factor authentication so what if
you're using two-factor authentication
you've got to enter a text code or
you're using Google Authenticator or
some other system that's gonna ask you
for that second piece of information how
do you do that well same story in here
when we call that identity management
system it'll usually push out that
second factor to the user and then they
can enter it into here we'd need to
provide an interface for them to be able
to enter it or some way to respond to
that but no problem with two-factor
authentication and definitely encourage
to keep things more secure we've got
another question on here somebody's
asking say I still have a lot of
questions is there a way to set up a
meeting to go into more detail
absolutely so go to the apogee web page
Apogee comm and look on there and find a
link on there to talk to sales and we
can set up a meeting for you guys I can
come there or somebody like me on my
team can come and we can set up a
meeting answer specific questions do a
full in-depth demo and talk about your
use cases is there any limit on the
expiration for tokens and token refresh
so no limit on that you can adjust what
the Refresh time and what the limit is
for the tokens so you can specify what
the time to live
us how many refreshes they get things
like that and that would be set to
whatever you want to set to next
question you know someone related from
that is is there an industry standard
for how long an OAuth token should be
valid for so no real industry standard
around that but talk to your security
folks they usually have requirements on
this what I've seen is a lot of folks
will match what they have on a website
so whatever their session timeout is for
their website a lot of times for API is
gonna be the same thing 30 minutes 60
minutes for things that are more
sensitive longer if they're not that
sensitive so that's what I've got for
questions all right and that's all the
questions that we've got right now so
stay tuned for the next session it's
gonna be how to enhance your G suite
efficiency with Chrome we're gonna
broadcast live from our New York office
so thank you very much for attending
today